[Music]
the simpsons are probably the most
popular animated series in the world
since december 1989 maggie marge lisa
houma and bart simpson have been making
families all over the world laugh
the series always has its finger on the
pulse of the time and regularly
questions and parody social events and
changes
however creator matt ronin himself
probably never thought that he would
predict so many occurrences as a result
sometimes it took only a few months
until a prediction turned to reality but
in other cases the prophecies came into
effect only years later
in this video we have summarized the
funniest and scariest predictions
many of you surely know the three-eyed
fish blinky that appears in quite a few
episodes
he made his first appearance in 1990 in
the fourth episode of the second season
where he can be seen near the nuclear
power plant
after the sighting the resins of
springfield rushed to the barricades
fearing a malformation caused by
radioactivity
however the owner of the power plant mr
burns explains that the fish's third eye
is merely the attainment of another
evolutionary stage
when he was then offered to eat the
specimen he turned it down
21 years later in 2011 a three-eyed fish
was actually
caught near the argentine city of
cordoba this is how blinky finally made
its way from being an allusion to the
consequence of radioactive wastewater to
actually becoming
a reality our next example also deals
with the impact of nuclear waste
in the episode from the 11th season the
simpsons fled to the countryside to
become farmers
to speed up the growth process of his
crops homer made use of the chemical
element
plutonium this worked splendidly but had
the side effect of causing tomatoes and
tobacco plants to crossbreed
the addictive tomekos came into being in
2013
14 years after the episode aired mutated
tomatoes were found near nuclear power
plants in japan
which looked quite similar to those of
homer
a crossing of tobacco and tomatoes also
exist regardless of atomic power plants
because one fan of the series enjoyed
the idea so much that he started
cultivating his own tomatoes
in 2003 his questionable culinary
creation
actually convinced the creators of the
simpsons to try his crossbreed
when they enjoyed it has remained
unknown
disney is undoubtedly the giant of the
entertainment industry
so it's not surprising that the studio
founded on october 16 1923
has already acquired many smaller film
studios in 2017
news then hit the media world that
disney was on the verge of taking over a
large part of 21st century's fox
business
the simpsons however apparently already
knew this in 1998.
in the episode when you dish upon a star
a movie poster clearly showed that 20th
century fox had become a part of disney
that's certainly also a reason why you
can currently watch all the simpsons
episodes on disney plus
the episode lisa's wedding released on
march 19 1995 is probably the one with
the most
actual predictions for the future the
yellow family visits a medieval festival
where lisa has her future predicted by a
fortune teller
she jumps to the year 2010 where our
predictions begin
the creators must have already thought
that there would be robots as librarians
in 2010 as you can see in a scene
at the beginning they were only off by
one year since the joe enrique manueto
library which is completely operated by
robots first opened in chicago
in 2011. it's only a few scenes later
that the next prophecy takes place which
turns out to be true
while lisa and her boyfriend hugh
parkfield are lying in bed you can see a
rolling stones concert to a poster in
the background
which was supposed to be a big tour in
2010 in the real world the band which
was founded in 1962
did not do so until 2012 but the
producers were once again
on the right track so when you and lisa
fly to visit his parents in england you
can see the silhouette of a large
building next to tower bridge
this is where the shark would later be
located but the tallest building in
europe was not built until between
2009 and 2012. whether this is a clear
prediction or rather a coincidence we
leave up to you
it seems that the authors also agreed on
the fact that there will be clocks in
the future that can show more than just
the time
so when hugh proposed to lisa we saw the
rough predecessor of the smartwatch
there was also a smartphone in the
episode because long before skype and
video calls existed
lisa was on the phone with her mother
marge to tell her the good news to do so
lisa uses a tv phone which in retrospect
can certainly be considered the
forerunner of today's smartphones
all in all our yellow profits make a
total of five predictions in a single
episode
the chubby family man is known for many
things no doubt
the role of genius physicist however is
not really given to him
things are different in the episode the
wizard of evergreen terrorists from the
10th season
homer who is going through a kind of a
mid-life crisis is definitely trying to
invent things that could change the
world
quite casually he writes a formula on
the blackboard
on closer inspection this formula is
very reminiscent of the same
mathematical equation
that is used to calculate the mass of
particles
however this was only discovered 14
years later
and is now known as the higgs boson
scientists have even revealed that
homer's formula is only slightly off the
real formula
is this still coincidence for many of
you the election of donald trump as
u.s president may have come as a
surprise the creators of the simpsons
however foresaw this 16 years earlier
in the episode part to the future lisa
can be seen as the acting president of
america
in the year 2030. however she is facing
a country that is on the brink of
bankruptcy due to the misdeeds of the
previous president
this predecessor is of course none other
than donald trump
this was also not completely pulled out
of thin air in the year 2000 as trump
had
also applied to the reform party's
internal primary elections for the
presidential campaign
in a treehouse of horror episode from
2008 presidential elections are once
again due in america
homer who's lucky enough to use a
digital voting machine for the first
time
determinedly pressed the name barrack
obama however the machine then thanked
him for voting for obama's opponent john
mccain
homer kept trying to press obama but the
machine kept jumping to mccain's name
when homer finally came to the
realization that the machine was rigged
the machine promptly killed him four
years later there was indeed electoral
manipulation in america when electronic
voting
machines from the state of pennsylvania
falsely converted obama's votes into
votes for
mitt romney the nsa scandal surrounding
edward snowden is probably still
pretty well remembered by most people at
the time the whistleblower revealed that
the usa
and the uk had been intercepting and
monitoring telecommunications data on a
large scale
and without suspicion since 2007
particularly in relation to the internet
in the same year the simpsons movie was
released while marge bart lisa and
maggie are on the run
they activate a tracking device that
transmits to an nsa building
there you can see thousands of employees
wiretapping everything and
everyone one of them then picks up the
family signal so that their trail can be
acquired in the episode politically
inept with homer simpson which first
aired in 2012
homer was allowed to be a guest on a
talk show due to an internet video
at one point the bottom running news
ticker reads europe puts greece on ebay
so far greece has not been offered on
ebay but many consider the growing
crisis of 2015 and the bond purchases of
the european countries as confirmation
that the simpsons
once again predicted a crisis
hardly any other disaster is the subject
of as many conspiracy theories and
alleged predictions as the attacks on
the world trade center on september 11
2001. allegedly there were also
references to this in the episode the
city of new york versus homer simpson
which was broadcast four years before
the terrorist act
in the episode sun barton daughter lisa
is seen holding up a brochure offering
bus rides for nine dollars
if you look closely you can see the twin
towers next to the nine dollars thus
forming the date
9 11. whether there was pure coincidence
or once again
clairvoyant powers of our friends from
springfield we
leave it up to you at this point
but our yellow friends don't just have a
good nose for uprisings
and scandals they've also been spot on a
few times in the past when it comes to
sports events
the first time was in 2014 in the
episode
you don't have to live like a referee
which was aired ahead of the world cup
in brazil
in the episode surrounding the world cup
homer is invited to brazil
as a referee crime bosses try to bribe
him in order to falsify the results
as chance would have it investigations
into bribery and corruption against
former fifa president said plata were
already
underway a year later however not only
were the simpsons right about this
they also predicted the world cup
holders in this episode
germany ultimately won the final against
brazil with a score of
to 0. in reality the opponent was
argentina but the creators were once
again
absolutely right with their prediction
that's it for today with prophecies that
actually turn out real
if you know any further predictions just
leave us a comment and who knows
your suggestion might be in the next
episode if you liked this video we would
appreciate a thumbs up and if you want
to see more videos like this
we highly recommend subscribing to us
[Music]
uh